und damit können wir jetzt in die
tagesordnung einsteigen und ich rufe auf
den tagesordnungspunkt 20 beratung des
jahresberichts
2021 der wehrbeauftragten
und für die aussprache wurde eine dauer
von 68 minuten beschlossen
das wort hat zunächst die
wehrbeauftragte des deutschen
bundestages
frau dr eva högl
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin meine sehr
geehrten damen und herren abgeordnete
der entsetzliche krieg in der ukraine
verändert alles für die soldatinnen und
soldaten bedeutet es dass es ernst
werden kann dass es schnell gehen muss
und dass sie immer einsatzbereit sein
müssen die bündnisse und
landesverteidigung dieser 2014 höchste
priorität hat wird jetzt sehr konkret
und unsere soldatinnen und soldaten
reagieren darauf mit hoher
professionalität und mit großer
ernsthaftigkeit und
zudem wird deutlich wofür wir die
bundeswehr haben und warum wir sie
brauchen unsere soldatinnen und soldaten
verteidigen frieden freiheit demokratie
und sicherheit und deswegen sage ich
ganz herzlich dankeschön
184.000 soldatinnen und soldaten die
jeden tag hoch motiviert engagiert
pflichtbewusst ihren dienst leisten
der jahresbericht enthält immer das
ganze soldatenleben von ausbildung bis
zulagen ich habe im jahresbericht 2021
auch neue themen beschrieben nämlich den
klimawandel und das thema sport denn
auch beim klimawandel trägt die
bundeswehr eine ganze menge dazu bei sie
ist in bereichen auch vorreiterinnen und
sport beschäftigt die bundeswehr nicht
nur im jahr der olympischen spiele
sondern auch jeden tag und dann gibt es
auch noch viel zu tun der jahresbericht
listet immer mängel fehler versäumnis
auf und im besten fall ist er eine
grundlage für verbesserungen die das
ministerium auf den weg bringt und
natürlich der deutsche bundestag ich
habe mir aber auch vorgenommen und das
ist auch in diesem jahresbericht wieder
der fall gute beispiele aufzuzählen
dinge zu erwähnen auf die wir stolz sein
können die erreicht wurden und die auf
gutem weg sind
wir bearbeiten jahr im amt der
wehrbeauftragten im jahr 4000 vorgänge
im jahr 2021 waren das
2606 individuelle eingaben von
soldatinnen und soldaten
ich habe 60 truppenbesuche absolvieren
können und ich bin wirklich dankbar dass
sich trotz corona viele gespräche führen
konnte und da sich 2021 auch endlich
endlich endlich in die einsatzgebiete
reisen konnte nach litauen nach mali und
niger
und ich bin gerade erst in jordanien und
im irak gewesen und an dieser stelle
lieber abgeordnete möchte ich ganz
herzlich dem amt der wehrbeauftragten
danken 64 kolleginnen und kollegen
bearbeiten die anliegen der soldatinnen
und soldaten mit erfahrung mit sorgfalt
mit engagement und mit viel herzblut und
6 der kolleginnen und kollegen sind
heute hier und ihnen danke
stellvertretend der hätte
ich habe gesagt 2021 war das jahr der
bundeswehr denn die truppe hat gezeigt
was sie kann weil der amtshilfe oder
beim ende des afghanistan-einsatzes die
bundeswehr war da wo sie gebraucht wurde
professionell und zuverlässig und die
bundeswehr ist jetzt so gefordert wie
nie und deshalb brauchen unsere
soldatinnen und soldaten beste
rahmenbedingungen
das betrifft material personal und
infrastruktur und ich begrüße deshalb
ausdrücklich das geplante 100 milliarden
euro sondervermögen und die erhöhung des
verteidigungshaushaltes das sind in
schweren zeiten gute nachrichten für die
ballistik
diese mittel rollen genutzt um die volle
einsatzbereitschaft wieder herzustellen
damit kann finanziert werden was in der
bundeswehr dringend benötigt wird und
ich sage ganz deutlich priorität sollte
vor allem die persönliche ausstattung
seien helme schutzwesten bekleidung
rucksäcke und ich freue mich deshalb
dass der bundestag dafür bereits 2,4
milliarden euro bereitstellt damit mehr
und schneller beschafft werden kann denn
das geld lieber abgeordnete muss schnell
und vollständig in der truppe ankommen
und dazu müssen
dazu müssen auch die prozesse
beschleunigt werden auch die 100
milliarden euro können nicht in den
hergebrachten verfahren ausgegeben
werden das vergaberecht muss vereinfacht
werden und wir brauchen in der
bundeswehr weniger bürokratie
beim material ist noch einiges zu tun
selbst in den einsätzen ist nicht alles
da was soldatinnen und soldaten für
ihren auftrag brauchen das betrifft die
ausstattung genau so wie das große gerät
und der grundsatz train suv von
ausbildung über übung bis zum einsatz
der kann leider nicht gewährleistet sein
und wenn deshalb das große gerät zu 77
prozent einsatzbereit ist im jahr 2021
dann ist das zwar eine kleine
verbesserung über die jahre aber das
reicht noch lange nicht aus und ist noch
nicht genug
ein thema personal möchte ich positiv
hervorheben dass es gelungen ist trotz
corona und das ist eine wirkliche
leistung der bundeswehr den
personalbestand auf demselben niveau zu
halten 183 1695 soldatinnen und soldaten
im jahr 2021 davon 26.600 sechs frauen
das sind 12,8 5% ich habe das thema
frauen im jahresbericht hervor gehoben
weil wir nämlich
2021 20 jahre frauen in allen teilen der
bundeswehr hatten das ist ein erfolg
ich verbinde das mit der forderung wir
brauchen mehr frauen in der bundeswehr
12,85 prozent reicht noch nicht aus und
wir brauchen vor allen dingen mehr
frauen in führungspositionen
das ganze thema personalgewinnung
personalentwicklung personalbindung ist
eine enorme aufgabe für die bundeswehr
und deswegen muss die gute angebote
machen sie muss aber auch ein
realistisches bild zeigen denn soldat
soldaten zu sein ist kein normaler job
und darauf muss die personalgewinnung
auch deutlich rücksicht nehmen mich
beschäftigt sehr das thema infrastruktur
wir haben einen investitionsbedarf bis
2034 von 19 milliarden euro und die
bauverwaltung der bundesländer schaffen
alle zusammen pro jahr eine milliarde
das heißt wir haben einen gewaltigen
investitionsstau und wenn ich in den
kasernen binden dann muss ich sagen der
zustand der unterkünfte gebäude der
sportplätze der schwimmhallen der
truppenküche ist nicht akzeptabel da
muss etwas passieren
2021 stand auch im licht des ende des
afghanistan-einsatzes fast 20 jahre
afghanistan-einsatz 93.000 soldatinnen
und soldaten waren dort im einsatz 59
haben ihr leben verloren viele sind
verwundet an körper und seele
zurückgekommen dieser einsatz hat die
bundeswehr verändert und deswegen ist es
so wichtig dass er auf gearbeitet wird
und ich hoffe sehr dass die enquete
kommission bald eingesetzt wird denn die
soldatinnen und soldaten erwarten dass
dass dieser einsatz und aufgearbeitet
wird und es ist auch wichtig meine damen
und herren für künftige und laufende
einsätze es muss klar sein mit welchen
zielen geht die bundeswehr in die
einsätze in welchen teilen der welt mit
welchem partner mit welchen mitteln in
welchem umfang und zu welcher dauer das
wollen die soldatinnen und soldaten
geklärt wissen
ich habe mich seit amtsantritt sehr
intensiv mit dem thema rechtsextremismus
befasst
rechtsextremismus ist eine gefahr in
unserer gesellschaft und deswegen auch
ein thema in der bundeswehr es gibt mehr
fälle von rechtsextremismus ich will
ihnen aber ganz deutlich sagen es gibt
eine gestiegene sensibilität und es gibt
dadurch auch mehr meldungen aus der
truppe ich beobachte ein konsequentes
vorgehen in der bundeswehr und ich habe
auch gute beispiele im jahresbericht zum
beispiel nach den vorgängen in litauen
oder den ereignissen beim wachbataillon
ist zügig gehandelt worden und ich will
ihnen auch sagen dass ich der auffassung
bin dass auch die spezialkräfte des
heeres das ksk in calw auf einem guten
weg ist
corona corona beschäftigt und belastet
die truppe und das stelle ich im
jahresbericht auch da es hat die volle
einsatzbereitschaft der bundeswehr
verzögert auch die vorbereitung der nrf
kräfte und deswegen ist es gut und
richtig dass die amtshilfe jetzt
geändert ist wir hatten
2021 bis zu 19.000 soldatinnen und
soldaten zur hoch-zeit zeitgleich im
amtshilfe einsatz das war eine grandiose
leistung und wir mögen uns nicht
vorstellen wie das in der pandemie
bekämpfung gewesen wäre ohne die
unterstützung der soldatinnen und
soldaten
aber meine damen und herren die
bundeswehr hat andere aufgaben die
amtshilfe ist sowie subsidiär und für
die krise und deswegen ist es gut dass
das jetzt geändert ist
ich ende mit dem thema wahrnehmung in
der gesellschaft es gibt jetzt eine hohe
aufmerksamkeit auf die bundeswehr das
tut den soldatinnen und soldaten gut
aber ich will noch mal sagen unsere
soldatinnen und soldaten brauchen
respekt anerkennung wertschätzung und
dank aber sie brauchen vor allen dingen
ganz viel interesse aus der gesellschaft
und auch hier aus dem deutschen
bundestag der bundestag hat
verantwortung für die bundeswehr und
deswegen freue ich mich in der nächsten
zeit auch viele gute beschlüsse und
entscheidungen hier im bundestag zur
stärkung und zur unterstützung unserer
soldatinnen und soldaten herzlichen dank
die vögel die
wehrbeauftragte des deutschen
bundestages zeigte sich dankbar dass der
bundestag 24 milliarden euro genehmigt
hat für die persönliche schutzausrüstung
das ist auch aus ihrer sicht dass der
größte mangel dass die soldaten ebenso
wohl im einsatz wie auch so nicht
genügend schutz persönliche
schutzausrüstung haben neben den vielen
anderen mängeln und insofern begrüßt die
ehemalige spd
die ehemalige spd abgeordnete hier die
100 milliarden euro die für die
bundeswehr zur verfügung gestellt werden
soll
und jetzt als nächste rednerin kommt die
zuständige
bundesverteidigungsministerium
für einen bericht der die mängel in
unserer bundeswehr klar beim namen nennt
im großen wie im kleinen dafür
herzlichen dankeschön wir sind darauf
angewiesen gewesen zu wissen wo es denn
wirklich parkt in der truppe musste dem
großen und dem kleinen fehlt und wo wir
dann aber auch gegen steuern können denn
nur der bericht alleine hilft ja nichts
sondern handeln ist gefragt werden
in der aktuellen situation
wir sehen jeden tag wird die
grausamkeiten des russischen
angriffskrieges gegen die ukraine und
wir können heute noch nicht sagen wie
weit putin seinen großmacht zwar
antreibt und deswegen war es noch nie so
wichtig in der geschichte unseres
wiedervereinigten landes wehrhaft zu
sein und das heißt wir brauchen eine
voll ausgestattete und einsatzbereite
bundeswehr die uns und unsere
bündnispartner schützt und der
jahresbericht hilft uns dabei dieses
ziel zu erreichen
dieser dritte der 163 jahresbericht
stellt ganz klar fest die frauen und
männer der bundeswehr haben auch 20 21
ihre leistungsfähigkeit ihrer
professionalität und verlässlichkeit
unter beweis gestellt und dafür ihnen
unser aller dank und respekt
gleichzeitig aber nicht der bericht
große erhebliche probleme offen und er
macht auch sehr deutlich wo diese
baustellen sind es besteht ein massiver
investitionsbedarf von der persönlichen
ausstattung über großgerät bis hin zur
infrastruktur und deswegen ist das 100
milliarden
sondervermögen für unsere bundeswert so
entscheidend wir sind nach den vielen
jahren des mannes auf diesen booster
dringend angewiesen um die materielle
einsatzbereitschaft schnell und
nachhaltig zu erhöhen eine erste
wichtige und von der wehrbeauftragten zu
recht deutlich angemahnten verbesserung
haben wir bereits auf den weg gebracht
wir starten die gesamte aktive truppe
bis 20 25 mit dem vollen umfang an
persönlicher einsatzbekleidung und
persönlicher schutzausrüstung aus und
damit sechs jahre früher als geplant das
war nämlich erst wird
2031 für die gesamte truppe geplant und
es ist gelungen und da möchte ich ein
herzliches dankeschön auch an die
haushaltspolitiker sagen dass es jetzt
gelungen ist das vorzuziehen und dass
wir alle möglichkeiten genutzt haben bei
den verträgen die bestehen dass
vorzuziehen die berühmt berüchtigte
die berühmt berüchtigte noch koppeln in
der truppe verschrien und ein
dauerbrenner in den wer berichten gehört
damit bald endlich der vergangenheit an
und wie gesagt ein großer dank an die
abgeordneten des haushaltsausschusses
ich weiß das war sehr kurzfristig die
ich mit dieser vorlage in den ausschuss
gegangen bin aber mir war es wichtig
alle möglichkeiten auszunutzen dieses
vertrags gab jetzt schnell zu agieren
unsere soldatinnen und soldaten stehen
im mittelpunkt und für ihre
schutzausrüstung müssen wir entsprechend
handeln
damit haben sie trotz vorläufiger
haushaltsführung und ohne viel papier
diese wichtige verbesserung möglich
gemacht und sie haben zum ausdruck
gebracht wir tun alles was für den
bestmöglichsten schutz und die
bestmögliche ausrüstung unserer
parlaments am bbi nötig ist das ist aber
erst der anfang die drohnen bewaffnung
ist bereits beschlossen und wird
umgesetzt duden f 35 kampfflugzeugen
führen wir vertragsverhandlungen mit
unseren amerikanischen freunden und die
entscheidung für den schweren
transporthubschrauber
steht kurz bevor und das macht deutlich
dass schaffen eine bundeswehr die
deutlich leistungsfähiger sein wird als
heute und dafür brauchen wir jetzt das
sondervermögen
meine damen und herren es geht aber
nicht nur um die unterfinanzierung
denn die alleine steht einer besseren
bundeswehr nicht im wege aber das macht
der bereich wehrbericht auch sehr
deutlich und ich will anhand von zwei
punkten ich bin da sehr dankbar frau
wehrbeauftragte dass sie diese auch so
deutlich angesprochen haben an zwei
punkten deutlich machen was wir auch
verändern müssen und das ist bei liebe
beileibe kein kleinkram wie das von
manchen gestrigen so angeführt wird
diese zwei punkte treffen grundlegende
werte und damit den inneren zusammenhalt
in der truppe und machen die entscheiden
über die attraktivität unserer
bundeswehr für guten nachwuchs beides
von grundlegender bedeutung für unsere
verteidigungsfähigkeit der erste punkt
ist das thema frauen in der bundeswehr
die wehrbeauftragte hat es beschrieben
seit zwei jahrzehnten stehen ihnen alle
laufbahnen offen dennoch liegt der
anteil der soldatinnen in der truppe nur
etwas mehr als 12 und das ist klar zu
wenig wenn vielfalt in all ihren
dimensionen ist nicht nur eine frage der
gerechtigkeit
sie bietet auch einen ganz klaren
praktischen mehrwert denn studien zeigen
diverse teams sind leistungsfähiger und
erfolgreicher und diverse arbeitgeber
sind sehr viel gefragte und deswegen
fordern wir auch gezielt weibliche
talente durch entsprechende programme
und wir untersuchen
unser personal management laufend auf
systematische barrieren gerade auch was
frauen in führungspositionen
betrifft und da sind wir auf einem guten
weg sagt aber auch da können wir noch
deutlich besser werden und da werden wir
noch deutlich besser und gleiches gilt
für den zweiten punkt der ebenfalls kein
kleinkram ist und zwar der umgang mit
extremismus insbesondere
rechtsextremismus in der bundeswehr die
anzahl der verdachtsfälle ist 20 21
weiter gestiegen ja das ist ein zeichen
dafür dass das bewusstsein dass die
sensibilität für dieses thema gestiegen
ist vor allem aber ist es auch ein
zeichen dafür dass es immer noch in
unseren reihen zu viele gibt die die
werte mit füßen treten für die sie ihren
eid gesprochen haben und das ist nicht
hinnehmbar meine damen und herren
weder
weder für den dienstherrn noch für die
überwältigende mehrheit der kameradinnen
und kameraden die fest zu unserer
verfassungsordnung stehen und deren
ansehen durch diese vorfälle beschädigt
wird und deswegen ist es nicht
hinnehmbar und wir müssen konsequent
dagegen vorgehen und wir treten allen
nationalistischen rassistischen und
verwischen indem entschieden entgegen
und werden das weiter konsequent
verfolgen meine damen und herren die
wehrbeauftragte stellt in ihrem
jahresbericht 20 21 fest unsere
soldatinnen und soldaten garantieren
frieden freiheit und sicherheit
20 21
die 20 32 damit das auch in zukunft gilt
müssen wir jetzt die notwendigen
voraussetzungen schaffen die frauen und
männer in der bundeswehr sind froh die
wehrbeauftragte an ihrer seite zu wissen
sie sind aber auch froh abgeordnete des
bundestages an ihrer seite zu wissen die
bereit sind ihre parlamentsarmee
bestmöglich auszustatten und bei der
entscheidung über das sondervermögen
können sie alle dafür ein klares zeichen
setzen vielen dank
eines verteilers ministerin christine
lambrecht hat den bericht der
wehrbeauftragten gewürdigt auch noch mal
ihre eigene rolle zur sprache gebracht
nämlich das jetzt 2,4 milliarden euro
genehmigt worden sind für den kauf
persönlicher schutzausrüstung das auch
dringend
notwendig frau lambrecht wie es auch
nochmal auf den geringeren zu geringen
anteil der frauen hin es gibt eine quote
bei der bundeswehr 50 prozent im
sanitätsdienst und 15 resttruppe beide
quoten sind nicht erreicht klar sind wir
erst für die cdu/csu
in den letzten 63 tagen haben wir hier
im bundestag so oft und intensiv über
die bundeswehr gesprochen wie schon
lange nicht mehr
das auch gut so denn wir als
parlamentarier haben unseren soldatinnen
und soldaten gegenüber eine besondere
verantwortung
lippenbekenntnissen große ankündigungen
reichen nicht taten müssen sehen
jahr für jahr zeigt der bericht der
wehrbeauftragten schonungslos den ist
zustand der bundeswehr auf er hält
schwarz auf weiß fest wie es wirklich um
die truppe steht im bericht vdr hügel
dient uns allen als wertvolle einordnung
und hierfür danke ich ihnen so wie ihr
in ihrem gesamten team
auf
176 seiten werden viele themen
angerissen zahlreiche davon wie zb
finanzielle ausstattung der bundeswehr
die ausbaufähige einsatzbereitschaft und
mangelnde infrastruktur haben wir in den
letzten wochen hier im parlament bereits
intensiv diskutiert die heutige debatte
gibt uns folglich die möglichkeit die
themen anzusprechen welche in der
letzten zeit zu kurz gekommen aber nicht
minder wichtig sind aber
lassen sie mich vorher anmerken auch
wenn die regierungsparteien der union
untätigkeit in den letzten
legislaturperioden vorwerfen die 2015 an
geschwulst angestoßenen trendwenden
zeigen schon länger erste erfolge wir
waren auf einem guten weg und die
weichen wurden richtig gestellt
doch die sicherheitspolitische samen
lage hat sich grundlegend verändert und
deshalb muss dieser kurs nicht nur
konsequent und zielgerichtet weiter
verfolgt werden sondern bedrohungs
gerecht intensiviert werden genau
deshalb ist es unerlässlich dass die
bundesregierung die angekündigte
zeitenwende durchzieht und konsequent
umsetzt doch signale aus der koalition
zeichnen ein anderes bild der zweite
regierungsentwurf für den einzelplan 14
die stagnierende mittelfristige
finanzziele für den selbigen die
infragestellung der zweckgebundenheit
des sondervermögens und letztlich auch
der hacker kurs der regierung bei der
lieferung schwerer waffen an die ukraine
sind hierfür nur einige beispiele
selbst ein neutraler beobachter würde
zur schlussfolgerung vom dass die
zeitenwende leider immer noch nicht in
den köpfen aller kollegen in der
ampelkoalition angekommen ist
es ist immer wieder beeindruckend was
unsere soldatinnen und soldaten aller
geschilderten widrigkeiten zum trotz
geleistet haben und weiterhin tagtäglich
leisten
das engagement unserer bundeswehr war im
berichtsjahr 2021 so vielfältig wie
selten zuvor dazu zählen unter anderem
die erfolgreiche evakuierung von
insgesamt 5.000 347 personen vom kabuler
flughafen über 17 millionen ab
geleistete arbeitsstunden von
soldatinnen und reservistinnen und sowie
soldaten und reservisten im rahmen der
korona amtshilfe sowie die unverzüglich
erfolgten einsätze in dem vom
jahrhunderthochwasser betroffenen dann
flutgebieten in nordrhein westfalen und
rheinland pfalz noch nie war die
bundeswehr so sichtbar wie im
vergangenen jahr erneut hat uns die
bundeswehr bewiesen dass wir uns stets
auf sie verlassen können dies ist auch
in der breiten gesellschaft so
wahrgenommen worden
der krieg in der ukraine und die damit
verbundenen verwerfungen im
sicherheitspolitischen gefüge haben zur
folge dass wir von jedem einzelnen
unserer soldaten in den kommenden jahren
noch mehr verlangen werden müssen als
wir es ohnehin schon tun eine
einsatzbereite und kaltstart fähige
bundeswehr benötigt aber nicht nur
moderne ausstattung und material
besonders in der jetzigen situation
müssen wir alle darauf achten dass wir
die lebenswirklichkeit und die sozialen
belange unserer soldatinnen und soldaten
in unseren parlamentarischen debatten
nicht zu kurz kommen lassen denn auch
die verteidigungspolitik hat eine
soziale dimension
mögen soldatin beziehungsweise soldat
nicht einfach nur als beruf ansehen
sondern als berufung unabhängig von
dieser selbst und fremdwahrnehmung sind
unsere frauen und männer in uniform
menschen mit ihrer ganz eigenen
lebenswirklichkeit
ob diese geprägt ist von
lebenspartnerschaften dem eheleben
kindern oder sonst die sonstigen
faktoren spielt eigentlich keine rolle
der dienst in der bundeswehr hat nicht
nur einen prägenden einfluss auf die
lebensumstände jeder soldat in und jedes
soldaten sondern auch auf deren
unmittelbares umfeld und auch angehörige
jedes uniformierte mitglied der
bundeswehr sowie dessen angehörige sind
sich bewusst wie geladen das
spannungsfeld zwischen familie und
dienst ist
die für die landes- und
bündnisverteidigung so wichtige
kaltstart fähigkeit wird diese
spannungsfeld noch verstärken
planbare auslandseinsätze die die durch
eine lange vorlaufzeit um vorkehrungen
zu die eigene abwesenheit ermöglichen
sind eben genau das gegenteil von kalt
stadt fähigkeit hier reden wir über die
nicht planbare kurzfristige
mobilisierung und verlegung von
tausenden soldaten auf unbestimmte zeit
mit sehr kurzer vorwarnzeit
die betreuungs und fürsorge angebote für
angehörige von bundeswehrsoldaten sind
gut aber
nicht im ansatz für solche größenordnung
ausgelegt
was bedeutet das konkret was bedeutet
das für die offizieren die zu hause
ihren vater pflegt was bedeutet das für
den feldwebel dessen zwei kinder noch
intensiv betreut werden müssen und erst
eine frau voll berufstätig ist und das
sind nur zwei von rund 184 1000
uniformierten bundeswehrangehörigen für
die wir eine antwort haben müssen es
muss
über den materiellen aspekt der
einsatzbereitschaft hinaus auch immer
der personelle aspekte der
einsatzbereitschaft mitgedacht werden
dazu gehört nicht nur betreuung und
fürsorge im einsatzland sondern auch für
die im heimatland befindlichen
angehörigen und familien
dies ist keinesfalls nur für den
momentanen personalbestand der
bundeswehr von relevanz sondern wird
sich auch maßgeblich auf die
attraktivität der bundeswehr als
arbeitgeber für das dringend benötigte
neue an zu wertende personal auswirken
wenn wir mehr von unseren soldatinnen
und soldaten jetzt und in der zukunft
verlangen werden dann ist es unabdingbar
dass wir auch bessere soziale
rahmenbedingungen schaffen in denen sie
ihren dienst entsprechend aussuchen
können
auch aus diesen gründen sind wir als
union davon überzeugt dass eine
nachhaltige und dauerhafte erhöhung des
einzelplan 14
zusätzlich zum sondervermögen dringend
notwendig ist
sehr geehrte kolleginnen und kollegen
wir müssen in gesamtkonzepten denken das
heißt die weniger offensichtlichen
implikationen des eingeschlagenen weges
zu berücksichtigen und adäquat zu
adressieren vielen dank
[Applaus]
ersten 4g war das für die cdu/csu sie
hat hier noch mal untermauert dass neben
dem 100 milliarden
auch der wta in zukunft angehoben werden
muss richtung 2 das ist ja die haltung
der cdu csu da wird sicherlich hinter
den kulissen noch viel diskutiert werden
ehe dann voraussichtlich im juni dieses
100 milliarden paket und die
grundgesetzänderung verabschiedet werden
kann
spielberg für die bündnisgrünen
2020 war das jahr der bundeswehr sie
haben es gerade selber nochmal gesagt
wie sie es im bericht geschrieben haben
für den herzlich danken möchte und ein
jahr das nicht nur für die gesellschaft
sondern eben auch für die bundeswehr
enorme herausforderung mit sich gebracht
hat zum einen kommt die unterstützung
der bundeswehr bei der bekämpfung tempo
der pandemie war außerordentlich der
truppe gilt hier mein großer dank
nun aber sollte sich die bundeswehr auch
wieder auf ihren kernauftrag
zurückbesinnen finden zum anderen auch
das wurde schon angesprochen afghanistan
nach 20 jahren vor ort haben wir unseren
militärischen einsatz dort beendet auch
hier bedanke ich mich bei allen
angehörigen der bundeswehr die dort eine
gute arbeit geleistet haben
die ziele wurden nicht erreicht aber die
verantwortung dafür liegt in der politik
auch in diesem haus die enquete
kommission und deren verantwortung wurde
auch angesprochen aber
ein bis 2021 auch gleich geblieben der
bericht der wehrbeauftragten zitiert zum
teil chancen doch in großer masse ist es
eher eine mängelliste und eine
aufzählung von lücken von fragen und von
problem
und als abgeordnete eines landes mit
einer parlamentsarmee sind meine ziele
folgendes eine vollumfängliche
persönliche schutzausrüstung für die
soldaten eine angemessene unterbringung
und versorgung die härteste bekämpfung
von rechtsextremismus und
gleichberechtigung in den streitkräften
und um die herausforderung auf dem weg
dahin deutlich zu machen möchte ich
einige zahlen aus dem bericht hervor
4 7 milliarden euro so viel wurde durch
die letzte bundesregierung im baum und
in sanierungsmaßnahmen verwendet aber
die werbeauftritte bescheinigt den
unterkünften den sanitäreinrichtungen
den truppen tischen und sportplätzen
dennoch endlich zum teil desolate
zustand und bei diesen anlagen liebe
kolleginnen handelt es sich ja nicht um
luxus räume sondern eben die
grundlegendsten einrichtungen für unsere
soldatinnen und
unser ziel ist dass planungs vorgänger
entsprechend zu beschleunigen den bau
neuer und die sanierung alter
einrichtungen eine höhere priorität
zukommen zu lassen
und eine weitere sache hat sich nicht
wirklich geändert
beschaffungsprozesse sind unflexibel
langwierig und nicht ausreichend
bedarfsorientiert und dadurch ergeben
sich teilweise extreme defizite in der
materiellen ausstattung der truppe und
wir fordern wie die werbeauftrag das den
soldatinnen gerade aber nicht nur im
einsatz um die bestmöglichste ausrüstung
zusteht und um dementsprechend hat die
jetzige bundesregierung
erste maßnahmen getroffen um diese
vernünftige ausstattung zu gewährleisten
zu ermöglichen und mit dem
sondervermögen wollen wir dies unter
anderem wort für
eine weitere zahl
1501 80 soldatinnen leiden bekannter
weise bis ende letzten jahres unter
einsatz folgen unter körperlichen und
seelischen folgen von auslandseinsätzen
und hier ist anzuerkennen dass es
bereits fortschritte gab zb durch das
einsatz weiterverwendung gesetz aber
gerade zum beispiel bei der
wiedereingliederung von soldaten hätten
den dienst bleiben weiterhin viele
hürden bestehen und unser ziel ist es
auch darüber hinaus dass jede soldatin
jeder soldat angemessen versorgt und
betreut
zur nächsten 2
589 so viele fälle von rechtsextremen
verhalten wurden vom militärischen
abschirmdienst gemeldet und das ist eine
deutliche zunahme auch bei gestiegener
sensibilität und für uns ist ganz klar
der großteil unserer soldatinnen steht
ganz fest auf dem boden des
grundgesetzes sie verteidigen die werte
der verfassung und schützen unsere
freiheit doch die steigende zahl an
rechtsextremen und reis bürger innen ist
mehr als besorgniserregend und noch
immer werden solche fälle von einigen
als einzelfälle abgetan und verharmlost
das kann und darf nicht sein
es braucht weiter eine höhere
sensibilisierung eine bessere prävention
durch gute politische bildung und das
klare bekenntnis zur inneren führung
rechtsextreme haben in der bundeswehr
nichts zu suchen
und zu letzten zahlen 2 das ist der
prozentuale anteil der frauen in der
bundeswehr auch das wurde gerade schon
angesprochen auch 20 jahre nach dem
urteil des europäischen gerichtshofs ist
die gleichstellung von frauen und
männern noch nicht überall in den
streitkräften selbstverständlich auch
das muss sich ändern
vor zwei tagen haben wir genau hier über
das sondervermögen zu landes- und
bündnisverteidigung debattiert es lässt
sich also bereits absehen dass die
bundeswehr auch in diesem jahr in 2022
eine überaus relevante rolle spielen
wird
der krieg in der ukraine und die
veränderte sicherheitslage in europa und
der welt werden auch die bundeswehr
prägt
und das ziel der bundesrepublik bleibt
das in europa und international dazu
beizutragen frieden zu schaffen und dazu
brauchen wir auch sicherheit und genau
dazu kann eben die bundeswehr ihren teil
beitragen und jetzt ist es eben an uns
als deutschen bundestag die
voraussetzung weiter dafür zu schaffen
dass die bundeswehr für die krisen von
heute aber eben auch für die krisen von
morgen gut aufgestellt ist dankeschön
merle spielberg hat gerade noch einmal
gesagt wie sie sich eine funktionierende
bundeswehr vor spielt natürlich dass die
soldaten schutzausrüstung haben es wird
in diesen tagen ein bisschen
anachronistisch dass man hier diskutiert
die mängel der bundeswehr und es stellt
sich immer die frage ob diese bundeswehr
in der lage wäre einen russischen
angriff abzuwehren hannes genau zwar hat
er war bis zum vergangenen jahr selber
zeitsoldat bei der bundeswehr meine
damen und herren im eingang des
werberings 20 21 heißt es die bundeswehr
würde bei der amtshilfe zeigen was sie
können und schon hier zeigt sich das
gute verhältnis der etablierten politik
zur bundeswehr unsere soldaten sind
soldaten sie sind keine aushilfskräfte
für privat dienstleister und keine
lückenfüller für die pflege oder andere
sektoren in denen ihre politik versagt
meine damen und herren es ist die
vielleicht in den letzten wochen wieder
vor augen geführt worden die kernaufgabe
der bundeswehr ist die
landesverteidigung
die truppe beweis nicht beim aushelfen
in fremden bereichen was sie kann
sondern den militärischen regelbetrieb
im täglichen kasernen dienst auf den
zahlreichen übungen ebenso wie im
auslandseinsatz dass sie die bundeswehr
seit ewigkeiten aber eben nicht wie eine
ernst zu nehmende armee behandeln
spiegelt sich auch in diesem werberecht
wieder zu wenig material zu wenig
personal veraltete strukturen gleich auf
seite 8 heißt es zitat kein
truppenbesuch und kein gespräch mit
soldatinnen und soldaten in dem wir
nicht von mängeln berichtet wird und
auch ich kann aus meiner aktiven
dienstzeit daraus ausführlich berichten
wir haben in den letzten wochen viel von
großgerät gesprochen doch fangen wir
doch beim elementarsten bei der
persönlichen ausrüstung des soldaten
fragen sie doch mal einen erfahrenen
mannschaftsdienstgrade oder porto pi und
offizier was dieser so in seiner
dienstzeit an eigenem geld in privat
beschaffte ausrüstung investiert hat
meine damen und herren ich gebe ihnen
brief und siegel sie erhalten als
antwort einen mittleren vierstelligen
betrag und das meine damen und herren
ist beschämend das kann doch nicht der
anspruch einer professionellen armee
seien
zwei beispiele aus der praxis erstens
die dienstlich gelieferten schießen
schuhe sind in der regel zu groß
insbesondere am zeigefinger ist die
passform eine katastrophe und deswegen
schneiden viele soldaten das innenfutter
heraus mit diesen handschuhen ist es für
jeden soldaten nahezu unmöglich morgens
um 7 auf der schießbahn bei minusgraden
das 80 20 verfahren sauber durchführen
zu können für die vaterlands kritischen
kräfte hier aus der linken ecke man
spannt den haaren bei der pistole bei
diesem verfahren zu 80 prozent vor und
lässt dann die verbleibenden 20
den schuss alleine kommen sollte man
wissen zweitens das veraltete noch
koppel system meine damen und herren es
wäre wirklich schön wenn unsere soldaten
sich nicht selbst funktionsfähige kampf
festen oder platten träger besorgen
müssten weil sie auf eintrag konzept
angewiesen sind das älter ist als der
kalte krieg eine weste mit der man im
inland trainieren kann und mit welcher
man gegebenenfalls in den
auslandseinsatz verlegt das benötigen
unsere männer und frauen bevor man
milliarden deutsches steuergeld für
großgerät ausgibt für das kein konzept
vorliegt und wo nicht klar ist ob diese
systeme kompatibel sind und woher man
sie überhaupt nehmen soll sollte man
doch lieber bei der persönlichen
ausrüstung des soldaten anfangen
frau strack-zimmermann da können sie
gerne zwischenrufen ich weiß ihm gefällt
dass wenn die einsteiger und offizier
eine heroische rede hält und neues gerät
allein
und neues gerät allein kann den menschen
nicht ersetzen den menschen der für sein
vaterland zu bluten bereit ist bei einem
meiner letzten truppenbesuche stellte
ich an einem kampf materien fest dass
nur 60 prozent der fällt die bestellen
besetzt sind meine damen und herren so
kann doch eine armee nicht funktionieren
und als ehemalige personaler sage ich
ihnen jetzt auch woran das liegt die
stellenbesetzung vom bundesamt für
personalmanagement muss wahrheitsgetreu
abgebildet werden was in der praxis
nicht immer der fall ist weiterhin
müssen die einplanen karrierecenter zu
den soldaten ehrlich sein denn die
meisten feldwebel brechen erst ab
nachdem sie die allgemeine militärischen
lehrgänge sowie ihre fach teile
absolviert haben und nach drei jahren
zum ersten mal in führungsverantwortung
in die kampftruppe kommen man muss die
jungen menschen bereits im
karrierecenter aufklären was sie dort
erwartet die truppe isst du mal zum
kämpfen da und dazu unser vaterland zu
verteidigen und ja da kann der ton auch
mal rauer sein ist ja ähnlich wie hier
wenn sie wenn sie den beruf des soldaten
allerdings nur mit geld anreizen
attraktiv machen wollen dann wird dies
scheitern soll das muss wieder berufung
sein und dafür muss der soldat
gesellschaft gesellschaftlich wieder mit
mehr ehre anstand stärke und status
assoziiert werden aber das ist natürlich
nicht möglich mit einer regierung die
sich gegen die toxische männlichkeit
einsetzt wie sie alle nun in
endlosschleife betont haben zeigt der
krieg in der ukraine dass die
konventionelle landesverteidigung eines
nationalstaates auch im
einundzwanzigsten jahrhunderts
überlebenswichtig ist schön dass sie
dies nun endlich begriffen haben doch
ihre einsicht erfolg viel zu spät das
beste beispiel ist die beschaffung
bewaffneter drohnen damit hätten viele
gefallene in afghanistan verhindert
werden können aber die spd hat sich über
etliche jahre hinweg dagegen gewehrt
nach knapp zwei jahrzehnten gruppe und
der auslandseinsätze mit tausenden
kameraden die mit körperlichen und
seelischen verletzungen heimgekehrt sind
gibt es immer noch keine bitterarmen
kultur in der bundesrepublik so als gäbe
es überhaupt keine männer und frauen die
für unser land gekämpft haben ja genau
ganz tschuldigung gestatten sie eine
zwischenfrage oder bemerkung dass
familien die vater oder mutter sohn oder
tochter bruder oder schwester verloren
haben und vielleicht nie wieder so
zusammenkommen können wie vor dem krieg
die von den ptbs betroffenen soldaten
mit nach hause gebracht haben keine
projekte keine offensiven zur
verbesserung der pflege oder
reintegration der veteranen zurück in
die gesellschaft im wehrbericht dazu
nicht mal eine vierte seite zu gender
und viel falls ideologie hingegen
mehrere seiten auch das sagt eigentlich
bereits alles auf ihre politischen
prioritäten haben nichts mit der
verantwortung für die soldaten zu tun
die sie in die auslandseinsätze schicken
meine damen und herren
das offenbarte sich ganz eindrücklich im
umgang mit dem truppenabzug aus
afghanistan
da heißt es auf seite 15 im wehrbericht
dazu politisch verantwortlichen nahmen
nicht an dem empfang teil weder
vertreterinnen noch vertreter der
bundesregierung noch des deutschen
bundestages das waren nachhinein
betrachtet ein fehler zitat ende und für
die nachträgliche er würdigung unserer
veteranen der afghanistan einsätze wird
im wehrbericht was vorgeschlagen frau dr
hügel eine briefmarke mehr nicht das
wäre angeblich ein schönes zeichen des
dankes wer so mit denjenigen umgeht die
für dieses land zu sterben bereit sind
kann einfach keine wer fähigkeit
herstellen denn das meine damen und
herren würde eine geistig-moralische
patriotische wende bedeuten und das
wissen sie und das fürchten sie wenn wir
als nation noch die wende schaffen
wollen muss das credo lauten weniger
klima gender und kritische theorie mehr
trainieren wie du kämpfst mehr treue und
liebe zum eigenen deutsche tugenden
statt links liberaler werte die mit der
realität einer armee nichts zu tun haben
es braucht eine alternative für die
bundeswehr wohl vaterland an erster
stelle steht und nicht vielfalt um jeden
preis vielen dank
hannes genau war das für die af.de der
bundestag debattiert den jahresbericht
20 21 der wehrbeauftragte eva högl die
wehrbeauftragte wird als hilfsorgan des
deutschen bundestages bei der
parlamentarischen kontrolle der
streitkräfte berufen und die vögel hat
sogar einen eigenen sitzplatz nämlich
neben der bundesratsbank dort sitzt der
wehrbeauftragte dort wird extra stuhl
aufgebaut denn in den meisten sitzung
ist sie hier nicht anwesend eine
bundestagsabgeordnete war sie mal aber
es
gibt jetzt von frank zimmermann fdp eine
zwischendecke
schneidigen unteroffizier oder soll ich
sagen an den schneidigen unteroffizier a
d
vielleicht herr kollege weil sie ja hier
sehr stark aufgetreten sind
beeindruckend ihre fraktion hat ja
gerade genau
können sie mal diesen hohen haus und
damit der öffentlichkeit erklären
unterstelle es ihn nicht dass sie keine
uniformen tragen dürfen dass sie nicht
mehr in die kaserne rein dürfen
vielleicht erklären sie das dem hohen
hause dass ein schneidiger unteroffizier
hd den mut hat hier so aufzutreten und
im namen der bundeswehr zu sprechen die
nehme ich dieses land verteidigt sind
sie immer noch dabei oder sind sie nicht
dabei herr unteroffizier schneidig
wer genau auf sie dürfen wenn sie
möchten antworten
frau schavan vielen dank für die
zwischenfrage dass ich mich hier auch
noch einmal erklären kann ich merke hier
die rede hat ihnen gefallen und auch mit
auftreten noch einmal zur klarstellung
dass ag steht natürlich deswegen hinter
meinem dienst gerade weil ich in den
deutschen bundestag gewählt wurde und
nicht weil ich aus der truppe entlassen
wurde es gab eigentlich richtig ist
disziplinarverfahren es gab lediglich
vorermittlungen zwei jahre lang zu einem
gerichtlichen disziplinarverfahren
dieses wurde nie eröffnet deswegen bin
ich immer noch soldat und wurde auf
vorwochen herzlich in meiner alten
kaserne empfangen vielen dank
es gab ein es gab einen zweiten wunsch
einer kurzintervention aus der
spd-fraktion von johannes als
dankeschön lieber herr kollege genau
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
ich möchte als offizier sagen der 19
jahre im dienst ist der 7
auslandseinsatz hinter sich hat sie
sprechen nicht für die bundeswehr und
nicht
mehr
johannes erhalt mitglied im
verteidigungsausschuss und sie haben es
gehört offizier der bundeswehr
genau sie haben das wort wenn wir
antworten nicht
[Musik]
ich glaube wir sollten jetzt alle mal
wieder ein bisschen runterfahren herr
genau hat es das wort
er genau hat jetzt auch das wort und
darf antworten ja hallo erstmal vielen
dank für ihren langen dienst in den
streitkräften und genau so wie sie heute
gar nicht hier in dieser debatte
sprechen sprechen sie alleine für die
spd fraktion und ich spreche für die afg
fraktion und viele millionen meiner
wähler darauf bin ich sehr stolz und ich
weiß auch wie viele soldaten jetzt
zuschauen und vor dem fernseher
applaudieren danke
wir gehen jetzt weiter in der debatte
und als nächster redner hat das virtual
lars lindemann für die fdp-fraktion
[Applaus]
frau präsidentin meine sehr geehrten
damen und herren liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen sehr geehrte frau doch der
hügel auch ich möchte ihnen im namen
meiner fraktion für ihre arbeit danken
und bitte sie darum dass auch an ihre
mitarbeiter die heute hier sind
weiterzugeben herzlichen dank für ihre
arbeit
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen die
wehrbeauftragte fungiert als mittler
zwischen parlament und der bundeswehr
zum schutz der grundrechte der
soldatinnen und soldaten als hilfsorgan
des deutschen bundestages also von uns
allen bei der parlamentarischen
kontrolle der bundeswehr dabei geht es
ganz wesentlich
in unserem auftrage um die stellung und
funktionalität der bundeswehr in der
verfassungswirklichkeit der
bundesrepublik deutschland über die auf
das jahr 20 21 bezogenen erkenntnis
untersuchungen verhält sich dann auch
der heute debattierte bericht liebe frau
dr
die ihnen übertragene aufgabe ist
ausdruck der ganz besonderen
verantwortung von uns allen hier im haus
gegenüber der bundeswehr für deren
fähigkeiten in der gesamtheit aber auch
für die soldatinnen und soldaten in
ausübung ihres berufes in konkreten
beide dimensionen sprechen sie in ihrem
bericht an sie haben darin
unzulänglichkeiten und auch
unzumutbarkeiten deutlich benannt ob uns
als parlament ist dann immer gelungen
ist auch bei den berichten der
vorgängerinnen und vorgänger immer die
richtigen schlüsse zu ziehen das müssen
wir wohl eingestehen waren nicht immer
der fall aber es geht bei einem solchen
eingeständnis mein lieber herr kollege
von der hfg eben nicht darum dass man
lautstark mit dem finger auf andere
zeigt sondern wir bemühen uns gerade im
palais katarische diskurs dieser
unzulänglichkeiten jetzt zu beseitigen
wissen sie zeichnet in den demokraten
aus dass er wenn er etwas erkennt in der
lage ist daneben auch die notwendigen
konsequenzen zu ziehen nach ihrem dunkle
quatsche hier kann ich nicht erkennen
dass sie in der lage sind solche
konsequenzen zu ziehen
aber es kommt etwas anderes hinzu der
vorgelegte bericht bezieht sich auf
einen zeitraum und er entstand in seiner
schriftlichen abfassung noch vor dem
bruch der europäischen friedensordnung
durch einen von russland begonnen einen
angriffskrieg auf die ukraine seit dem
24 februar bekommen wir alle jeden tag
unsere verletzlichkeit vor augen geführt
und auch die notwendigkeit einer
wehrhaftigkeit unserer demokratie darum
möchte ich nicht auf die im bericht gut
nach lesbaren und detailliert
dargestellten einzelheiten eingehen
meist sind sie auch länger bekannt ich
würde gern liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen
etwas anderes hinzufügen deutschland ist
nicht unmittelbare kriegspartei wir
wollen dies weder selbst noch in der
nato als bündnis werden aber der krieg
ist nicht nur geografisch nah er bewegt
und erschüttert uns alle ganz
individuell auf unterschiedliche art und
weise die sichtbaren auswirkungen des
krieges wie zum beispiel die ankunft und
die unterbringung von flüchtlingen
das für mich und die überwiegende
mehrheit in diesem land körperlich
spürbare mitleid mit den ukrainischen
volk die verbale durchaus heftige
debatte um die frage und den richtigen
weg ob wir schwere waffen in die ukraine
liefern das ganz individuelle vom
wohlstandsverlust für mit
wohlstandsverlust verbundene aushalten
von auswirkungen der sanktionen hier in
deutschland das alles sind nur zum glück
vorstufen und nicht vergleichbar mit dem
was wir für unser land was andere
aushalten müssen wenn es krieg auch für
uns hier geben würde sie alle hoffen
dass dies bei diesen vorstufen bleibt ob
dies tatsächlich so sein wird kann
niemand sagen liebe frau dr es ist darum
in ihrem nächsten bericht und in ihrer
arbeit bis dahin noch viel stärker
darauf einzugehen dass sie begleiten und
kontrollieren und am ende auch
transparenz dafür schaffen ob die von
uns in diesen tagen auf den weg
gebrachten maßnahmen zur ertüchtigung
unserer bundeswehr tatsächlich und ganz
besonders in der wahrnehmung der
soldatinnen und soldaten am anfang der
berichts kette tatsächlich wirksam
werden es geht um unser aller
glaubwürdigkeit dabei gegenüber den
soldatinnen und soldaten und auch
gegenüber unserem land dies ist
notwendig damit unser nun eingeschlagene
weg der beschleunigten und aufwändigen
ertüchtigung der bundeswehr die
akzeptanz hier im parlament aber auch in
der deutschen gesellschaft bereit ich
danke ihnen für ihre aufmerksamkeit
die der beauftragte des bundes der
bundeswehr so was wie die anwältin der
soldaten im vergangenen jahr gab es 2006
106 persönliche eingaben von soldaten
das waren weniger als im jahre 20 20 und
jetzt gibt es nur ein ordnungsruf
betitelung des kollegen genau gehört aus
den reihen der spd-fraktion
und für diesen ausdruck den sie
genannt haben
[Musik]
erteile ich denen das sage ich ihnen
jetzt den kollegen christian petri einen
ordnungsruf es ging um den ausdruck
dummschwätzer
und wir haben uns hier alle vereinbart
dass wir uns hier nicht gegenseitig mit
irgendwelchen titeln beleidigen und
insofern profis die der zuordnung und
damit
kommen wir wieder zur debatte
und als nächstes hat das wort die
kollegen aus der fraktion die linke
jacqueline nass
also ordnungsruf in die eigene fraktion
von bärbel bares als unparteiische
parlamentspräsidentin gegenüber
christian petry und jetzt also zeigt den
mast xi ist die obfrau der linksfraktion
im verteidigungsausschuss
auch die fraktion die linke der
beauftragten für den bericht allerdings
dürfte auch im hinblick und in
verbindung mit einigen aussagen der
wehrbeauftragten einige fragen auf die
bundeswehr ist einsatzbereit sagte frau
hügel bei der vorstellung des berichts
und das klingt ja erst mal etwas anders
als das sonst wiederkehrende mantra die
bundeswehr seien schlecht aufgestellt
und hätten nicht genügend geld in den
vergangenen 20 jahren ist der
werbeetat verdoppelt wurden von 26,5 auf
52,8 milliarden wenn also etwas schief
läuft dann liegt das wohl nicht an
mangelnden geld sondern am völligen
missmanagement der politisch
verantwortlichen an schlechten verträgen
und fragwürdigen berater verdienen
und deutschland braucht dringend die 100
milliarden aber nicht für weitere
aufrüstung sondern für bildung für
gesundheit und gute renten das sind
unsere besten waffen
und frankreich zeigt ja dass es geht
frankreich hat ein innen ähnliches
militärbudget wie deutschland aber da
gibt es kein dauer mantra und
lamentieren über die medien über panzer
die nicht geradeaus fahren und gewehre
die nicht gerade aus schießen also
sollten eigentlich die politisch
verantwortlichen beginnen gerade
auszudenken und aufhören das geld der
steuerzahlerinnen zu verschwenden
es mutet doch etwas komisch komisch an
ausgerechnet lobend afghanistan zu
erwähnen dass das kein ruhmesblatt war
liegt weiß gott nicht an den soldatinnen
oder soldaten oder mangelnden geld
sondern dieser fish tank von beginn an
vom politischen kopf her und einige
diese köpfe sitzen immer noch in diesen
rein
mindestens
285.000 zivilistinnen wurden in
afghanistan grausam ermordet im land
herrscht eine humanitäre katastrophe um
mit dem taliban sind die gleichen
machthaber wieder an der macht die
angeblich sonst aufgabe von den in
afghanistan vorher befreit werden sollte
und warum verschleppen sie den
untersuchungsausschuss zu afghanistan
frau hügel hat das ja richtigerweise
angemerkt dass er dringend notwendig ist
und immer also wehrbeauftragte dürfte ja
bekannt sein dass die bundeswehr laut
grundgesetz eine verteidigungsarmee es
stattdessen reden sie aber vom
bündnisverteidigung die nato hat sich
weder in diesen grausamen tagen noch in
den jahren zuvor als ein friedensbündnis
erwiesen also machen sie also machen sie
sich nicht von einer wehrbeauftragten zu
einer werbe beauftragten brüstung
industrie bitte fahren sie bitte den
überparteilichen charakter einer werbe
auftraten und vor allen dingen den
charakter der bundeswehr als eine
parlamentsarmee und
die linke schließt sich ausdrücklich im
ort an diejenigen soldatinnen und
soldaten an die rechtsextremismus nicht
in ihren reihen dulden wollen und
meldung erstatten schade dass es bei der
bundeswehr aber nicht in diesem hohen
hause geht es braucht viel klarer diese
grenzen gegen rechtsextreme auch unter
den reservisten im vergangenen jahr
wurden
1033 sachverhalte mit extremismus bezug
innerhalb der bundeswehr ermittelt
helfen sie dringend frau hügel dieses
aufzuklären wie so steigen die
verdachtsfälle wieso gibt es so viele
radikalisierung unter den reservisten
und in welcher form werden wir
dienstvorgesetzten in die pflicht
genommen
hier ist der bericht leider nach
ziemlich dann meine damen und herren
trotz des politischen und des medialen
säbelrasseln haben die ostermärsche
gezeigt wie wichtig es vielen tausenden
menschen in deutschland ist sich für
abrüstung und frieden auf die straße
zugegeben dafür zu demonstrieren und das
war ein gutes zeichen frau b 1 war auch
dass ihr anliegen ich hoffe das
vergessen sie nicht vielen dank
frau lastig hat sich die wehrbeauftragte
vorgenommen allerdings muss man die
berichte dann auch lesen denn die
wehrbeauftragte hügel hat im
zusammenhang mit afghanistan kein
untersuchungsausschuss gefordert sondern
eine enquetekommission das sind dann
doch schon feine unterschiede
nächste redner jetzt aus der spd falko
droßmann
er ist mitglied im
verteidigungsausschuss und das ist heute
hier seine erste rede vor dem wohnhaus
[Applaus]
ja sehr geehrte frau präsidentin sehr
geehrte wehrbeauftragte dr
liebe kollegin auch im namen der spd
bundestagsfraktion den ganz herzlichen
dank für diesen 63 cents vorgelegt haben
meine damen und herren der uns
vorliegende 63 bericht der
wehrbeauftragte dieses hauses zeichnet
in guter tradition
ein objektives bild des zustandes
unserer streitkräfte und unserer
bundeswehrverwaltung ein bild das frei
ist von parteilichen tendenzen aber
parteiisch ist für unsere soldatinnen
soldaten und zivilbeschäftigten wie jede
und jeder vorherige inhaberin dieses
wichtigen amtes hat aber auch eva högl
ihre eigenen schwerpunkte gesetzt vor
allem begrüße ich die besondere
betrachtung der situation von frauen in
der bundeswehr sowie den neuen
schwerpunkt der umwelt und
klimapolitischen herausforderungen
unserer truppe
ihnen
ihnen frau bundesministerin lamprecht
danke ich ausdrücklich wie die schlüssel
die sie aus diesem bericht gezogen haben
und ich bin mir sicher dass wir diesen
bericht nicht nur als sachdarstellung
sondern als arbeitsauftrag verstehen
denn das ist der
denn das ist eher ein arbeitsauftrag und
so wurde in den letzten jahren auch
verstanden fühlt man sich die
plenardebatten der letzten jahre einmal
zu gemüte finden wir auch den immer
wiederkehrenden parlamentarischen ablauf
regierungsfraktionen loben das
ministerium opposition fordert endlich
konsequenzen aber liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen der bericht des
wehrbeauftragten des deutschen
bundestages richtet sich nach meinem
verständnis doch gerade nicht an das
bundesverteidigungsministerium
sondern an uns als parlament
es ist es ist doch unsere aufgabe und es
ist unsere werbeauftritte die uns um die
zustand die besonderen leistungen und
fehlentwicklungen unserer bundeswehr
unserer parlamentsarmee berichtet ich
möchte an dieser stelle mit ihrer
erlaubnis frau präsidentin aus dem
player produkt heute 93 sitzung des
deutschen bundestages vom 28 juni 1955
zitieren dort sagt der großartigen
sozialdemokrat erich ollenhauer nämlich
jede militärische streitmacht ist nicht
nur ein teil der exekutive sondern sie
schafft aus ihrem wesen heraus ein stück
verfassungsrechtlicher wirklichkeit
neben der exekutive weil sie nach völlig
anderen grundsätzen aufgebaut ist als
die zivile verwaltung und weiter der
demokratische aufbau und die zivile
verwaltung sind daher nicht garantiert
in dem das militär die weisungsbefugnis
der weisungsbefugnis des
verteidigungsministers der
verteidigungsministerium unterstellt ist
und in dem es die verantwortlichkeit des
bundeskanzlers gegenüber dem parlament
gibt die position der streitkräfte sagt
ollenhauer muss durch direkte einwirkung
möglichkeiten des parlaments gesichert
sein
und meine damen und herren wenn wir den
begriff parlaments
nehmen dann ist es doch unsere aufgabe
die notwendigen änderungen vorzunehmen
wie kommt es denn dass unsere
streitkräfte derzeit in einem zustand
sind der ein sondervermögen überhaupt
nötig macht liegt es nicht auch darin
daran dass wir es hier in diesem haus in
den letzten jahren versäumt haben den
streitkräften einen klaren auftrag zu
geben und sie entsprechend unseres
auftrages auch auszustatten wohl nicht
stattdessen ohne langfristige strategie
eine vielzahl von waffen system mit der
folge geschafft dass wir eine schier
unübersichtliche modellvielfalt haben
alles etwas können aber viel zu wenig
richtig liebe kolleginnen wie alle
beklagen eine überbordende bürokratie
oder sprechen gar von managementfehlern
in der sogenannten beschaffung aber sind
es nicht wir die regeln aufgestellt
haben das auch noch jede kultur jede
tube schuhcreme in einem langen
verfahren öffentlich ausgeschrieben
werden muss oder jede erprobung neuen
materials erst während der ausschreibung
des ausschreibungsverfahrens stattfinden
darf und dann beklagen wir uns über zu
lange bearbeitungszeiten der bundeswehr
sind es nicht wir die den bundesländern
und kommunen personal für bau und
sanierung militärischer einrichtungen
zur verfügung stellen nicht aber über
prüfen wofür dieses personal tatsächlich
eingesetzt wird sind es nicht wir die
über das stvg festgelegt haben dass auch
noch jeder panzer bei dem ein blinker
nicht richtig bringt vorübergehend
stillgelegt werden muss sind es nicht
wir die zu recht betroffen und
erschrocken die beispiele von
führungsversagen und verletzung der
freiheitlich demokratischen grundordnung
lesen und aufklärung und harten
maßnahmen fordern ohne dass wir uns
fragen was die ursachen sind wie kann es
denn sein dass eine wachsende anzahl von
soldatinnen und soldaten gerade in
führungspositionen das bild des
staatsbürgers in uniform hinterfragen
und einen soldaten sui generis fordern
oder sich hohe und höchst gestellte
offiziere nach beendigung ihres dienstes
den rechtsradikalen gruppen
zusammenschließen und mit hoher
pensionen jene freiheitlich
demokratischen grundordnung bekämpfen
die sie vorher tapfer also unter einsatz
ihres lebens verteidigen sollten einige
beispiele finden wir auch auf der
rechten seite des hauses hier
sie können dazwischen brüllen aber
ehrlicherweise ich bin seit mehr als 20
jahren ich bin seit mehr 20 jahren offen
ich bin seit mehr als 20 jahren offizier
und meine haltung ist glasklar der
funktionär in der ard ist ist weder als
offizieren noch als unter offizieren der
bundeswehr tragbar
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen nein es
ist die aufgabe dieses parlament es sich
um eben diese fragen zu kümmern um die
attraktivität des dienstes um die frage
was in afghanistan falsch gelaufen ist
um die bezahlung der soldatinnen und
soldaten wobei wir uns natürlich darum
kümmern müssen dass die zulagen aus der
dienst der soldaten auf das ruhegehalt
angerechnet werden wie dies für andere
und die vom träger des bundes
angekündigt wurde um die herausforderung
an militärische führung die ausstattung
die unsere aufträge erst ermöglicht und
die innere führung und sauerland und
unsere freiheit als mündige staatsbürger
innen zu verteidigen und verteidigen zu
können und zu wollen liebe kolleginnen
auch das ist zeitenwende werden wir
unserer verantwortung als parlament
wieder gerecht vielen dank
die ersten rede von falko droßmann
bedacht mit viel applaus aus den eigenen
reihen auch die bündnisgrünen klatschen
beifall
rednerin für die cdu csu fraktion ist
die kollegin sehr rasch kühler
[Applaus]
frau präsidentin liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen sehr geschätzt auch
wehrbeauftragte zunächst möchte ich
ihnen so dr möbel ihnen und ihrem team
danken für ihren unermüdlichen einsatz
und ihre konstruktive arbeit gänzlich in
unserer soldatinnen und soldaten
in ihrem jahresbericht
2021 bekommen wir aufschluss über den
zustand der bundeswehr sowie auch über
die stimmung und auch über die
missstände in der truppe aber auch in
anderer hinsicht ist der bericht sehr
aufschlussreich bereits zu beginn ihres
berichtes gehen sie auf die rede des
bundeskanzlers am 27 februar an dieser
stelle ein und auch sie haben ganz
offensichtlich den bundeskanzler genau
so verstanden wie der rest der
bevölkerung
deutschland wird ab sofort mehr als zwei
prozent des bruttoinlandproduktes in den
verteidigungshaushalt investieren und
zusätzlich
zusätzlich ein sondervermögen
bundeswehr in höhe von 100 milliarden
euro aufsetzen nachzulesen in dem
bericht der wehrbeauftragte lieber herr
kollege aber okay das soll anders
gemeint gewesen sein das muss vorher
geld es muss ich das muss der rest der
bevölkerung hier zur kenntnis nehmen und
dennoch dennoch möchte ich hier
klarstellen dass wir ausdrücklich ihre
aufforderung frau hält an dieses
hochhaus ihre aufforderung unterstützen
im verteidigungshaushalt deutlich zu
erhöhen wir müssen dauerhaft mehr als
zwei prozent des bips in die bundeswehr
investieren das erwarten unsere partner
und so verbündeten aber genau das
erfordert auch die aktuelle
bedrohungslage nur dann die auch so groß
angekündigte zeitenwende wirklich mit
leben gefüllt werden denn ihr bericht
zeigt das geld wird dringend gebraucht
gerade für die persönliche ausstattung
und ausrüstung unserer soldatinnen und
soldaten und davon konnte ich mich auch
letztens im rahmen eines besuchs bei
unserer battle group in litauen
überzeugen das muss man an dieser stelle
leider auch ganz offen und ehrlich sagen
unsere soldatinnen und soldaten vor ort
sind diejenigen die am schlechtesten
ausgestattet sind und das obwohl wir
dort führungs nationen sind das fängt an
bei der bekleidung geht rüber zu
funkgeräten sowie aber auch dass unsere
soldaten nach wie vor die einzigen sind
die im gepanzerten fahrzeugen mit karten
arbeiten müssen während andere schon
digital unterwegs sind und wer dafür
verantwortlich ist lieber herr kollege
das haben wir glaube ich in den letzten
tagen hier sehr sehr erörtern und klar
ist geworden dass sich hier keiner von
dieser verantwortung freisprechen kann
gerade nicht ihre fraktion dabei
es ist auch unsere größten faktor möbel
gerade auch schon deutlich gemacht das
ist ausdrücklich zu begrüßen es hier in
guter zusammenarbeit zwischen der
bundesregierung und dem bundestag die
2,4 milliarden euro für die
schutzausrüstung und für die bekleidung
jetzt schnell und flexibel
bereitgestellt werden dies wird die
motivation der männer und frauen noch
mal steigern
und es ist ein zeichen des respekts
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen darüber
hinaus müssen wir aber auch weitere
bedürfnisse der soldatinnen und soldaten
im auge behalten und auch hier
insbesondere der frauen diese
bedürfnisse müssen stärker in den fokus
gerückt werden denn sie stellen zu recht
fest frau bögl dass die strukturen der
bundeswehr auf männliche soldaten
ausgerichtet sind es ihnen immer noch
knapp 13 prozent nur knapp 13 prozent
frauen in der bundeswehr also müssen wir
uns auch hier hier gemeinsam als
abgeordnete gedanken machen wie wir den
dienst in der bundeswehr für frauen
attraktiver machen können zum beispiel
müssen dienst und familienpflichten
kombinierbarer werden die vereinbarkeit
von beruf und familie ist ein großes
thema in der aktiven truppe aber aber
auch bei den reservistinnen und
reservisten
sie müssen viele verpflichtungen
miteinander koordinieren zwischen ihren
beruf ihrer familie und dem reservisten
dienst auch ihnen danke ich ausdrücklich
für ihr engagement
gerade in der fluthilfe oder auch in der
pandemie ihre rolle für die landes- und
bündnisverteidigung
wird in diesen zeiten wieder zentral für
die verteidigungsfähigkeit unseres
landes im verteidigungsfall müsste eine
große zahl reservisten herangezogen
werden die reden hier von mehreren
zehntausend doch die software dafür die
diese mammutaufgabe stemmen soll stammt
aus den zeiten des kalten krieges die
digitalisierung und personalwesen muss
also schneller und flexibler gestaltet
werden und kann sich nicht an die
normalen beschaffungswesen wege halten
die mittlerweile mehrere jahre dauern
können bis dahin ist eine
implementierung bzw die it der
implementierung schon längst überholt
und das ist nur eine der möglichkeiten
der unsere soldatinnen und soldaten
teilweise ausgesetzt sind wie wir in dem
bericht nachlesen können und umso
bemerkenswerter ist es wie
selbstverständlich und höchst motiviert
sie immer wieder außerordentliches
leisten und dafür gilt ihnen unser aller
dank liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
strengen wir uns gemeinsam an ziehen wir
gemeinsam lehren aus diesem bericht und
sorgen dafür dass motivation und freude
am dienst für unser land stärker
gewürdigt werden indem wir die belange
der truppe auch künftig stärker
respektiert
herzlichen dank
der bundestag debattiert über den
jahresbericht 20 21 der
wehrbeauftragten und die nächste
rednerin kommt von den bündnisgrünen
sara nanni sie ist die
sicherheitspolitische sprecherin ihrer
fraktion
der bericht und der kontinuierliche
dieses kontinuierliche am puls der
truppe seien sind eine sehr wichtige
unterstützung unserer parlamentarischen
arbeit
der bericht zeigt die werde das von der
truppe im letzten jahr war enorm im
rahmen der amtshilfe haben soldatinnen
fiel auch das getan was eben nicht zu
ihrem kernauftrag der landesverteidigung
gehört im impfzentrum im gesundheitsamt
im alten pflegeeinrichtungen haben sie
im rahmen der pandemie überall dort hand
angelegt wo es nötig war und ich sage
ihnen auch ganz ehrlich manche kommunen
sind mit der bereitschaft zu am 24
verantwortungsvoller umgang als andere
und auch in der flutkatastrophe im juli
120 mit ihren verheerenden folgen für so
viele menschen waren soldaten im einsatz
die buchhaltung bäume und trümmer aus
flussbetten und von straßen zu räumen
die soldatinnen haben hier enormes
geleistet sie haben den dank der
bevölkerung direkt gespürt und ich denke
ich spreche für das ganze haus wenn auch
ich hier leider sage
danke sagen aber nicht das zeigt der
bericht liebe vor wehrbeauftragte und
ich habe es auch selbst erfahren als ich
ende dezember letzten jahres im ruckler
die truppe bei der in health verpressung
drittel gut besucht habe dort habe ich
mit soldaten gesprochen und sie
erzählten von ihrer arbeit die schon
damals in einem sicherheitspolitisch
sehr angespannten umfeld stattfand und
auch über ihre persönliche ausstattung
im einsatz haben sie gesprochen und auch
darüber dass die ausstattung nicht immer
angemessen ist sie beschaffen sich in
der konsequenz dass eine oder andere
teilen auch nicht alles ganz billig
selber und die bundeswehr ist eine
parlamentsarmee und auch wenn wir
einsätze wie in ruka nicht montieren wir
sind doch verantwortlich wenn die truppe
unzureichend ausgestattet ist wenn er
soll er ordentlich aber nicht üppig ist
teilweise dafür draufgeht dass man erst
mal die persönliche ausstattung so
vervollständigen muss dass man sein
auftrag optimal erfüllen kann das muss
doch anders gehen
und ich will dich liebe frau ministerin
auch optimistisch dass es anders gehen
wird ich bin der ministerrat auch dem
generalinspekteur sehr dankbar auch dem
haushaltsausschuss natürlich dass sie
als eine der erste entscheidung in
dieser wahlperiode ganz klar gemacht
haben es wird kein soldat und keine
soldaten werfen und persönliche
ausstattung bangen
das ist nicht nur ein wichtiges signal
dass etwas mit respekt zu tun und
respekt heißt so viel mehr
und da bleiben wir weiter in der pflicht
ihr bericht 176 seiten sind das sind
hausaufgaben für das bmvg aber auch für
dieses haus
respekt heißt aber auch dass frauen in
der bundeswehr selbstverständlich sind
und sexismus geächtet wird dass menschen
unabhängig von religion sexueller
orientierung und geschlechtliche
identität
hautfarbe oder biografie alle gleich
behandelt werden
und das heißt auch dass
kameradschaft nicht denjenigen
das dass die kameras und das heißt auch
dass die kameradschaft nicht derjenige
gefährdet der rechtes gedankengut
anprangert sondern derjenige der es in
die truppe trägt
das heißt auch dass wir im parlament
sehr genau prüfen in welche einsätze wir
unsere soldatinnen mit welchem auftrag
zum senden und dass wir diejenigen die
mit seelische und körperliche kunden
zurückkommen gut versorgen das ist
insbesondere mit blick auf das ende des
afghanistan einsatzes wurde hier
mehrfach angesprochen ein großes thema
dem wir uns noch mehr widmen möchten die
bewerbe auftrag
2606 persönliche eingabe
3967 vorgänger insgesamt haben sie und
ihr team im letzten jahr ausgewertet in
zahlreichen besuchen bei der truppe
haben sie zugehört und haben sich
ansprechbar gezeigt danke dass sie ihre
arbeit so gewissenhaft machen damit wir
unsere arbeit gewissenhafter machen
können
so jetzt muss ich noch ein paar dinge
klarstellen volllast ich finde es
unangemessen dass ihr der
wehrbeauftragten hier unterstellt den
auftrag nicht gerecht zu werden der
bericht zeigt das gegenteil
dieser stelle ist und haben und all die
union nur eine frage sie haben ja
wichtige herausforderung angesprochen wo
waren denn die parlamentarier der union
die letzten 16 jahren
zu ihm komme ich noch die afg hüfte
reihen der erste mann der gedient hat
sie haben glaubt im bundestag gerettet
weil er in der truppe keine perspektive
mehr hatte das ist doch die wahrheit und
wissen sie was für
kameraden die sie stellt man sich in der
bundeswehr
die reden der rft ins glacis niemand der
dieses land und diese werde die dem
dieses land und diese werte am herzen
lägen biedert sich einem autokraten wie
putin so an wie sie das regelmäßig in
diesem haus tun
sara nanni war das für die bündnisgrünen
der bundestag debattiert hier über den
jahresbericht der beauftragten sie hat
heute morgen den bericht aus der furcht
hält auch die verteidigungsminister hat
bereits gesprochen und gelobt dass der
bundestag 24 milliarden euro
bereitgestellt die persönliche
ausrüstung her genau um den es hier
schon häufiger ging hat jetzt noch nicht
vor weil sie mich ja persönlich
angesprochen haben nicht die ard hat
mich in den bundestag gehievt oder
gerettet in meinem wahlkreis habe ich
das zweitstärkste ergebnis geholt mit
über 20 der direktmandats stimmen ihr
kandidat herr kerner landete bei 3
prozent die bürger als deutschen volkes
haben mich hier rein gewählt und nicht
die fdp hinein gehievt oder gerettet das
muss man klar gestellt werden vielen
dank
[Applaus]
ich rufe auf den nächsten redner für die
fdp-fraktion alexander müller
präsidentin liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen frau hügel ich darf ihnen
zuerst für ihren engagierten einsatz für
unsere soldatinnen und soldaten danken
mit ihrem bericht legen sie wieder die
stellen offen an denen die politik im
obligo ist die probleme der truppe
abzustellen es ist ein ganz wichtiges
papier eine art checkliste würde ich als
berufs pilot sagen die wir in diesem
haus abzuarbeiten haben ihr bericht 20
21 geht ausführlich ein noch das ende
des afghanistan einsatzes eine zäsur in
der geschichte der bundeswehr
afghanistan war der intensivste und der
verlustreichste auslandseinsatz der
bundeswehr der bericht ist erneuter
anlass zum gedenken an die 59
soldatinnen und soldaten die aus diesem
einsatz nicht wieder lebendig nach hause
gekommen sind dann auch an die vielen
körperlich und seelisch verwundeten für
deren fürsorge wir hier als parlament in
der schuld stehen wir danken heute allen
unseren soldatinnen und soldaten die
weltweit für uns den kopf hinhalten um
unsere aufträge zu erfüllen und frieden
in der welt abzusichern
jetzt kommen wir mal kurz zu den zahlen
der kollege von der afg sprach eben von
seinen millionen wählern beim
bundeswahlleiter kann man es ja sehr
genau nachvollziehen es waren 26.000 wir
sind also ein paar nullen will
durcheinandergeraten aber auch über die
cdu muss man sich doch heute wundern
weil beide rednerinnen und das ist ja
schon fast vergnügungssteuerpflichtig
ist ein finanzministerium keiner da der
mir am hut rumgehen könnte aber das war
schon unterhaltsam also die union hatte
in der mittelfristigen finanzplanung der
letzten bundesregierung waren für dieses
jahr 46 milliarden und ein paar
zerquetschte vorgesehen gewesen wir als
ampel haben 50 milliarden auf den tisch
gelegt und dann kritisieren sie und die
ama nach rum und dann kommt das
sondervermögen und da stehen sie ja auch
nicht da wissen sie auch nicht was sie
wollen also der fraktionsvorsitzende
mehrzahl angekündigt 75 stimmen will er
uns gönnen für die grundgesetzänderung
mit den 100 milliarden und der rest
stimmt dann irgendwie anders also das
heißt sie sind entweder in der union
tief gespalten oder sie wollen hier
taktische spielchen spielen und das ist
unangemessen für die wenn es um das wohl
unserer soldatinnen und soldaten geht
das ist kein staatspolitisches handlung
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen gestern
haben hier mehrere redner verlangt dass
wir die ukraine nicht weiter bei der
selbstverteidigung unterstützen sollten
dass wir putin nicht weiter stören
sollten wenn er die bevölkerung dort
auslöscht die stammtisch formel wer
waffen liefert befeuert immer den krieg
die stimmt nicht viele von uns die
geglaubt haben man könnte ohne waffen
oder abschreckung dauerhaften frieden
haben sind in diesem jahr in der
realität aufgewacht wladimir putin
beeindrucken keine gespräche in
interessiert doch das völkerrecht nicht
und geschlossene verträge interessieren
hier auch nicht seine gegner bringt da
einfach um wir sind hier in deutschland
zeuge dabei ein aggressor stoppen wir
nicht mit einem sitzkreis und ausgiebige
diskussion das haben fast alle
mittlerweile verstanden ein aggressor
beeindruckt nur wirksame abschreckung
oder ich zitiere ein gutes zitat meiner
kollegin strack-zimmermann verhandlungen
aber mit sichtbarer hand am puls unserer
abschreckung ist eine starke bundeswehr
in der ukraine verteidigt sich gerade
die freie welt gegen den neoliberalismus
erst wenn freiheit das recht auf leben
auf körperliche unversehrtheit
fähre gerichtsurteile meinungsfreiheit
wenn das plötzlich nicht mehr vorhanden
ist dann erkennen wir deren wert die
bundeswehr ist unser garant für genau
diese freiheitlichen werte und ich bin
froh und dankbar dass die bundeswehr
jetzt auch verstärkt neue bewerberinnen
und bewerber bekommt weil sie den sinn
stiften kann den viele junge menschen
aus ihrem künftigen beruf ziehen wollen
jede unserer soldatinnen jeder soldat
riskiert seine körperliche
unversehrtheit und dient dafür diese
unsere art zu leben zu verteidigen
ich bin allen dafür sehr dankbar und
deswegen sollten wir noch wesentlich
mehr leisten für den respekt in die
truppe sich verdient und zu diesem
respekt gehört eine anständige
ausrüstung materielle ausstattung die
diese regierungskoalition jetzt
nachhaltig und glaubwürdig bereitstellt
vielen dank
die nächste redner kommt von der cdu das
ist florian hahn erst der
verteidigungspolitische sprecher der
cdu/csu-bundestagsfraktion und er kommt
natürlich von der csu
[Applaus]
ja sehr geehrte frau präsidentin
kollegen und legen jetzt hat der kollege
christian petry lada den saal verlassen
aber ich möchte man sagen also ich habe
dass er als einen kameradschaftlichen
hinweis von kollegen petri verstanden an
den kollegen genau aber das sei nur so
noch vorweg gestellt
sehr geehrte frau wehrbeauftragte vielen
herzlichen dank für ihren 63 bericht
nicht ihren sondern den 63 bericht des
wehrbeauftragten des hilfsorgan des
deutschen bundestages und vielen dank
dass sie einmal mehr den finger in die
wunde gelegt haben und wieder sozusagen
eine mängelliste in form dieses
berichtes vorgelegt haben was die den
zustand unserer der ausrüstung
ausstattung etc aber auch die sonstigen
angelegenheiten unserer soldatinnen und
soldaten angeht und auch wenn sie nicht
zuständig sind für die gesamte
bundeswehr sondern nur für die 184000
soldatinnen soldaten möchte ich einfach
weil sonst auch das ein bisschen oft
untergeht möchte ich auch sagen dass
nicht nur die 184000 soldatinnen
soldaten eine tolle arbeit und leistung
ablegen sondern auch alle zivilen
mitarbeiter die für und bei der
bundeswehr arbeiten und das möchte ich
an dieser stelle auch mal sagen
wow wehrbeauftragte sie haben in ihrer
rede viele wichtige punkte angesprochen
sie haben beispielsweise auch wieder auf
die amtshilfe
rekrutiert und da möchte ich sagen ja es
ist gut dass die amtshilfe jetzt beendet
wurde oder in weiten teilen beendet
wurde aber ich will sagen wir sollten
nicht nur feststellen dass es richtig
ist dass sie beendet wurde sondern wir
müssen mit blick darauf was in diesen
zwei jahren amtshilfe allein für das
thema krone was an ausbildung nicht
geleistet werden konnte was an problemen
dadurch bei der bundeswehr tatsächlich
auftritt sollten wir jetzt auch den
hinweis groß werden und zwar an bund
länder und an die entsprechenden
institutionen die eigentlich für diese
aufgabenerfüllung zuständig gewesen
wären jetzt die lehren daraus zu ziehen
und diese strukturen für die zukunft
aufzubauen denn wir werden das
tatsächlich nicht noch einmal in diesem
ausmaß leisten können und das müssen wir
denjenigen die dafür verantwortlich sind
auf allen ebenen auch ins stammbuch
schreiben frau wehrbeauftragte sie haben
beim thema ausrüstung ausstattung auch
wieder einmal auch hier den finger in
die wunde gelegt und es ist richtig dass
wir hier viele defizite haben und
darüber diskutieren wir ja schon jetzt
munter seit vielen vielen wochen und das
wird auch sicherlich noch ein paar
wochen so weitergehen wichtig ist dass
wir tatsächlich natürlich zu einem punkt
kommen und tatsächlich verbesserung
erreichen ich komme da noch das aber ein
wichtiger punkt dabei ist natürlich das
thema beschaffung und organisation von
beschaffung und wir brauchen hier
weniger bürokratie wir brauchen ein
schnelleres vorgehen schnellere
entscheidungen etc und deswegen war ich
sehr
ja positiv gestimmt als bei den ersten
äußerungen im amt die bundesministerin
angekündigt hat hier beim thema
beschaffung dann schwerpunkt ihrer
arbeit draufzusetzen und dann wurde kurz
danach berichtet freudestrahlend dass
man jetzt also schon mal die bei der
anhebung der unterschwelligen
beschaffung jetzt von 1000 auf 5000 euro
geht und dann wurde noch berichtet dass
man jetzt in zukunft noch mehr oder
öfters die möglichkeit nach europäischen
recht nutzen möchte auch ohne
ausschreibung zu beschaffen
und aber das war es bisher ich will nur
sagen das ist nicht der durchbruch wenn
wir darüber reden wie wir tatsächlich
beschaffung tatsächlich besser
organisieren wollen und der truppe
tatsächlich schneller und effektiver das
an die hand geben wollen was sie
tatsächlich braucht hier braucht es mehr
alarm frau bundesministerin und das
erwarte ich und wenn ich sie sagen das
sehen dass das sondervermögen von 100
milliarden ein booster ist dann bin ich
nur sagen passen sie auf dass dieser
booster nicht zum rohrkrepierer wird und
wir stehen im sondervermögen deswegen so
wie sie es jetzt wollen so kritisch
gegenüber weil sie nämlich erstmal
scholz erst angekündigt hat er möchte
gerne 100 milliarden plus dass zwei
prozent ziel und daraus wurde jetzt 2
prozent - 100 milliarden und das werden
wir so nicht mittragen können denn wir
werden dann 1 erleben dass wenn wir der
meinung sind heute dass in der
vergangenheit die bundeswehr
unterfinanziert war strukturell
unterfinanziert dann werden wir das wenn
dieser strohfeuer 100 milliarden
verbraucht es genau dort wieder landen
wenn wir bis dahin die finanz linien
nicht auch die zwei prozent nato ziel
gebracht haben und das wissen sie und
deswegen werden sie sich auch diesen
vorwurf gefallen lassen müssen machen
sie aus diesem aus diesem sondervermögen
nicht ein wirklich einen booster und
nicht ein strohfeuer und geben sie der
bundeswehr was sie braucht nämlich zwei
prozent zu viel und zwar für nicht nur
jetzt und dieses jahr sondern für die
nächste dekade herzlichen dank
florian hahn hier nochmal mit der
forderung der cdu csu
des 2 prozent ziels für die ausstattung
wird und dass wer dirk für bild jetzt
für die spd-fraktion
frau präsidentin
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen sehr
geehrte frau wehrbeauftragte dr hügel
dem dank an sie und ihr gesamtes team
kann ich mich uneingeschränkt
anschließen für alle die sich einen
überblick über die aktuellen themen in
der bundeswehr verschaffen möchten ist
der bericht der wehrbeauftragten eine
unverzichtbare lektüre
verständlich und mit vielen
anschaulichen beispielen muss man kein
fachpolitiker sein um in die großen und
kleinen probleme unserer parlamentsarmee
einzutauchen
das amt der wehrbeauftragten in
deutschland ist weltweit einzigartig und
auch das besondere verhältnis von
bundestag und bundeswehr zurückzuführen
und es ist der bundestag der über die
einsätze unserer soldatinnen und
soldaten entscheidet der sie ausstattet
und ausrüstet und der eine besondere
verantwortung für alle angehörigen
unserer streitkräfte trägt
der jahresbericht zeigt eindrucksvoll
auf was unsere soldatinnen und soldaten
im letzten jahr geleistet haben
von der amtshilfe im kampf gegen korona
und der bewältigung der
hochwasserkatastrophe über die einsätze
im rahmen unserer unseres
internationalen engagement bis hin zur
evakuierungs mission in afghanistan
zum teil ohne große vorlaufzeiten und
mit hoher einsatzbereitschaft
waren unsere soldatinnen und soldaten
auch im vergangenen jahr stets zur
stelle und packten dort mit an wo sie
gebraucht wurde
dass die bundeswehr amtshilfe leisten
kann ist spätestens seit der geleisteten
unterstützung im gesundheitsbereich
allen bekannt hier waren bis zu 19.000
soldatinnen und soldaten gleichzeitig im
einsatz amtshilfe darf aber nicht zur
daueraufgabe werden liebe kolleginnen
und kollegen der kernauftrag der
bundeswehr ist die landes- und
bündnisverteidigung
und um diesen auftrag erfüllen zu können
braucht sie gutes personal und material
das bundesministerium der verteidigung
strebte zuletzt in seiner
mittelfristigen personalplanung bis 2027
eine personalstärke von rund
203.000 soldatinnen und soldaten an mit
stand vom 28
februar 22
leisteten fast 184 1000 frauen und
männer ihren dienst bei der bundeswehr
das ist eine differenz von fast 19.000
da haben wir also noch große aufgaben
vor uns vor uns positiv festzuhalten ist
zunächst dass es der bundeswehr gelungen
ist trotz pandemie bedingte
einschränkung ein personalbestand von
99,8 prozent des vorjahres niveau zu
halten und die neubewerber zahlen im
vergleich zum vorjahr weiter zu steigern
auch die zahl der soldatinnen und
soldaten auf zeit mit einer langen
verpflichtungszeit von 15 jahren oder
mehr ist in den letzten jahren stark
angestiegen um die personal lücke zu
schließen muss die attraktivität der
bundeswehr als arbeitgeberin weiter
gesteigert werden um das zu erreichen
sind weiterhin erhebliche anstrengungen
nötig die im jahresbericht geschilderten
probleme bei der vereinbarkeit von
dienst und familie
notwendige verbesserungen der
rahmenbedingungen beim laufbahn wechsel
und die reduzierung unbesetzter
dienstposten will ich hier nur
exemplarisch nennt wenn die bundeswehr
neues personal finden und dauerhaft
halten möchte spielt gute ausstattung
eine elementare rolle
über die defizite bei der
einsatzbereitschaft von großgeräten
haben wir letzter zeit bereits
ausführlich diskutiert vom anspruch
trainers you feiert ist die bundeswehr
immer noch viel zu weit entfernt
bei der persönlichen bekleidung und
ausrüstung gab es positive entwicklung
vielen dank frau ministerin lambrecht
dass sie gerade in diesem bereich einen
ersten schwerpunkt gesetzt haben mehr
und schneller schon 2025 wird die aktive
truppe mit der lange geforderten
persönliche schutzausstattung
ausgestattet sein sechs jahre früher als
ursprünglich geplant so kann man muss es
weitergehen
die zahlreichen berichte über den
schlechten zustand von unterkünften
sanitäreinrichtungen sportstätten und
anderen gebäuden sind jedoch beschämt
selbst wenn die finanziellen mittel
vorhanden sind so scheitert es bisher
und das teilweise seit jahren an der
umsetzung vieler bauvorhaben es ist
höchste zeit die probleme mit den
bauverwaltungen der bundesländer zu
lösen die werbeauftrag quartier zu einem
appell an die ministerpräsidentinnen und
ministerpräsidenten der länder gerichtet
den ich noch mal deutlich unterstreichen
möchte liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
der werbe rechtzeitig auch wenn es im
letzten jahr viele positive
entwicklungen gegeben hat bis zu einer
vollumfänglichen ausstattung unserer
bundeswehr in allen bereichen haben wir
noch einen weiten weg nun gilt es das
geplante sondervermögen schnellstmöglich
und effektiv auf den weg zu bringen
vielen dank dirk viertel hat hier als
letzte rednerin ganz wichtigen punkt in
seiner rede angesprochen nämlich die
bundeswehr als arbeitgeber attraktiv zu
machen die rekrutierung neuer
kräfte das ist ihr in diese diskussion
eigentlich etwas zu kurz gekommen
das war also die debatte über den
jahresbericht 20 21 und in der tat wenn
man hört dass die persönliche ausrüstung
bis zum jahr 2025 jetzt bereitgestellt
werden soll damit einem angst und bange
wenn man die aktuellen ereignisse denkt
die gerade in der kleine stattfinden und
die durchaus ja nicht so weit entfernt
sind von unserem bundesgebiet und wenn
man dann noch hört dass 2025 sechs jahre
schneller dann die ausrüstung reitstalls
wie ursprünglich geplant war dann weiß
man wo unter anderem die probleme bei
der bundeswehr im verein die
bundeswehrverwaltung hängen und insofern
ist die vorgesehene 100 milliarden
spritze zwar sehr großzügig aber
offensichtlich notwendig um hier die
defizite auch gerade in der
waffentechnik schnell
so jetzt darf ich ihnen noch ganz kurz
sagen weil es um den abgang eines genau
die ganze zeit ja die alles genau ist
vom immer die tatsächlich als
rechtsextremist eingeschätzt worden er
hat offen gegen asylbewerber und
ausländer hetzt er war personal
feldwebel durch die letzten monate
seiner dienstzeit ich hör auf seinem
posten verbringen und wurde dann in den
deutschen bundestag gewählt und als
einer von vier abbrennen die afc in den
verteidigungsausschuss was bei den
anderen fraktionen zu keinerlei
begeisterung führte dass der hintergrund
zu der doch häufen auseinandersetzung
mit dem redner hannes genau im
verteidigungsausschuss sitzt er für die
afd